[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday August
7th I'm very lucky they have a kitty in
my lap hey hi kitty I'm gonna lay down
on you oh so cute anyway to start out
today I have a question to ask you
concerning your last video
sometimes I'm leery of what is being cut
out that sensation occurred to me during
your last video and I would like to roll
a clip can we do that quick can we can
we roll the clip the bad news is that
the Yeti has absolutely vetoed the
ex-girlfriend punishment she feels like
you know I've tortured them enough with
the radio pieces and all of that stuff
did you catch up to see what I was
looking got there oh dude let's just
look at it again you know I've tortured
them enough with the radio pieces and
all of that stuff yes right there I kind
of want to know what you're thinking
about right there feels like you might
have continued on after that sentence
that seems like you know what you mean
by all of that stuff I'm not sure that I
know I would like to know what you mean
by all of that stuff I just went to
Daniel bise's act blue profile and your
page has had over 100 donations for over
$2,000 amazing but this means that we've
skipped over a bunch of punishments and
you at the very least have to whack some
of my choosing while breaking the afib
raking the well breaking that while
breaking the peeps eating well breaking
the PV while breaking the beeps well bit
well breaking the peeps eating world
record set by punk record fighter nert
Hertford wax LM of my choosing while
breaking the peeps eating world record
set by punk rock nerdfighter Kurt oh and
now you all know that I stutter a lot
and cut probably 90% of what I record in
a day
additionally Daniel Biss had his biggest
traffic day ever yesterday and if you go
to a food calm now you'll notice that he
is second only to a guy called John
Edwards hmm I feel like I've heard his
name welcome to the age of the
nerdfighter it's very cool that
nerdfighters can help each other out and
that resident mathematician Daniel
Business campaign is spin a fitting so
strongly from the awesomeness of
nerdfighters and also that we're going
to get to see John do something
ridiculous
painful I really would like to see the
blenderize happy meal but that would
mean a hundred more donations and I
don't know if we can do it but I'm
willing to ask nicely blend Erised happy
meal only 96 donations away and donating
is really easy you have to give at least
a dollar and you have to have a credit
card you have to be a US citizen and you
have to be over 18 it really sucked that
we exclude young people from the
political process but we do though I am
kind of in favor of excluding citizens
of other countries from participating in
our political process because that would
be kind of weird sorry about that if you
want you can give 50 cents or $1 to the
foundation in Turkey's world suck and we
will count that towards the total but it
won't actually go to Daniel Biss but it
will go to decrease worldsuck and that
is all I have to say today look at your
conference thingy hi to all of those
people that I said hi to me yesterday
that was more people than ever said hi
to me before amazing and John I'll see
you tomorrow